Bonjour !
Bah bienvenue !
C'est mon nouveau chez moi.
Bon bah... c'est des ruines...
Maudites.
Ça s'appelle le château de la sorcière.
Parce qu'apparemment, avant, y avait une sorcière qui vivait ici.
Et c'est même là, qu'elle aurait tué le Père Noël.
C'est intéressant.
Ça y est, maintenant, je suis un vrai paysan.
Et ça me va très bien.
Le château me manque pas du tout hein.
C'est juste que, bon, y a un mode de vie un peu différent.
Par exemple, quand je cris "servaaaaaaaaant".
Rien ne se passe.
Oui ?
Ah oui. Non, non.
Servant, lui, c'est son nom.
Jean Servant.
Non c'est bon Jean, c'est bon, c'est bon.
C'est bon ?
Ouais, c'est bon.
Chouette gars.
La vie c'est un équilibre.
Y a des gens qui sont seigneurs.
Y a des gens qui font des chaussures.
Y a des gens qui ramassent des bouses de chevaux pour en faire des meubles.
Ça c'est nous.
L'important...
C'est qu'on ait tous un rôle.
J'ai peut-être plus de pouvoir...
Mais j'ai plus de problèmes.
Et j'ai plus de molaires non plus !
Voyez, elles sont tombées.
Ça doit être la bouffe.
Bon.
J'ai discuté avec des seigneurs de l'extérieur du Royaume.
Et on est célèbres pour deux choses.
Les mecs qui ont pas d'armée.
Et les mecs qui vendent des potions.
Génial !
Non, c'est ringard.
On peut pas essayer de viser un truc un peu plus haut là ?
Genre le trône de fer ?
Ouais.
Ouais, le trône de fer.
Mais pour ça, il nous faut une armée.
Alors, voilà à quoi je pense.
On démarre doucement.
Avec 100 000 hommes.
On colonise les provinces alentours.
Et on s'étend.
On s'étend.
Attends... Il a jamais été question qu'on envahisse les provinces.
Ça c'est parce qu'avant, on était des victimes de pharmacien.
Maintenant, on est des dragons.
Avec des balls !
Ah non, non, mais moi, coloniser, c'est contre mes principes.
Mais on colonise pas !
On répand la culture.
C'est pas ça que tu voulais ? Le théâtre...
Tous tes trucs.
Non, non, non...
Parce que le théâtre c'est pas exactement ça...
- Bon, vous en pensez quoi ?
Pour une armée de 100 000 hommes, il faut beaucoup d'argent et...
Voilà. Donc on va pas le faire.
Oh... mais soyez pas défaitiste comme ça !
On va trouver un truc.
Je crois qu'on a fait une connerie.
Alors... j'avais pas assez de matière pour faire une chaise.
Du coup, je vais appeler ça...
Tabouret.
C'est nous !
Ah, mais qu'est-ce que vous foutiez ?
J'ai eu le temps de faire au moins 8 meubles en bouses là.
Alors, on travaillait au terres là, hein.
Pour quoi faire ?
Pour manger.
Attention, ouais.
Attend, y a que ça là ?
De quoi ? Non, eh, oh !
Faut enlever les impôts là.
En plus, ils vont pas tarder à passer.
Les quoi ?
Les impôts.
Pour le seigneur.
Alors, ça c'est pour la protection. Voilà.
La location des terres.
C'est du vol là !
Bah... oui.
Oui... c'est pas toi qui l'avait instauré à l'origine ça ?
Ouais...
Si.
Le mec s'auto-scandalise.
Olala, oui !
Impôts sur le soleil.
Fait gaffe parce que celui-là, si on le paie pas, il nous coupe le soleil.
On à l'air fins nous après.
Ça laisse pas beaucoup.
Salut les crados ! C'est pour les impôts.
Habituellement, c'est pas le seigneur qui vient chercher les impôts.
Mais là, j'avais envie de le voir.
Oh le look !
J'adore !
Ah... t'es venu te moquer.
Sache que je passe des moments absolument merveilleux ici.
Je suis venu te donner des nouvelles du château.
Tiens !
Ça, c'est tes bannières.
Si tu veux les garder.
Parce que nous, on en a fait faire d'autres.
Des plus stylés.
C'est l'emblème de ma famille, tu peux pas faire ça !
Si, je peux tout faire, je suis le chef.
Ah !
Et ta devise là.
Les mystères sont de mise.
- Non !
Je l'ai faite changer en "les dragons dragonnent".
Espèce de...
Non, non, non, ça sert à rien !
Aaaaah... J'ai passé un super après-midi.
Non mais c'est pas possible, c'est dégueulasse.
Les gars, il faut lutter contre ce gouvernement qui nous opprime.
Et qui nous pousse dans la précarité la plus totale.
Ouais.
Donc, qui est pour un soulèvement populaire et un rééquilibrage des pouvoirs ?
Et on ferait ça quand ?
Ça pourrait être intéressant...
Qui est pour plus de bouffe ?
Ah oui, oui, nous on se bouge hein.
Bon, ce que j'ai compris, c'est qu'ils marchent à la graille quand même.
Dès que je dis "bouffe"...
Ça les rend dingues !
Donc, nous allons former un groupe anti-gouvernement.
Et je vais appeler ça...
La résistance.
Ou tabouret !
Ah !
Yorel.
J'ai besoin qu'on augmente notre chiffre d'affaire.
On pourrait partir sur un nouveau parfum d'huiles essentielles.
Est-ce que tu connais...
Le chèvrefeuille.
Je veux m'acheter une armée de 100 000 hommes.
Ok.
C'est là que j'ai besoin de ta créativité Yorel.
En fait, j'aimerai que tu inventes un produit...
Dès que tu y goûtes, tu trouves ça super.
T'es heureux.
Mais dès que tu en as plus...
Tu déprimes, t'es pas content...
Tu tombes malade.
Tu tousses, t'es pas bien.
Un peu comme de la drogue ?
Quoi ?
Yorel.
T'es en train de dire que je veux faire de la drogue ?
Tu me traites de voyou ?
Non...
Non, non, c'est juste qu'en fait, tu parlais d'une substance...
Où si les gens en ont pas, ils tombent malades.
Donc du coup, j'ai pensé... enfin j'ai trouvé ça...
Parfait.
Voilà.
C'est très bien ça, fait ça.
J'ai déjà le nom.
La froguine.
C'est de la drogue.